[Music]
the reimagined archie comics hit
cw teenage soap riverdale has old fans
fawning and newcomers
obsessing the dark series revolves
around murder and lust but what dark
secrets is the show trying to hide
warning don't watch this if you haven't
seen the entire show
do you want to be a diy expert check out
our friends at crafty hackers they have
the best hacks crafts and
everything diy watch their videos for
the best household tricks diy decor
and fun recipes if you love making
crafts with your friends or just trying
new things they have everything you're
looking for
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any awesome hacks and crafts
[Music]
now on to 10 dark secrets riverdale
tries to hide
three leads were turned down from the
series riverdale could have looked
crazily different from the cast we tune
in to watch today
three of the lead roles were actually
turned down after their auditions can
you guess who these three main actors
were
it's hard for us to even imagine the
show without them have your guesses
the three actors turned down were kj
appa camila mendez
and lily reinhardt yes the iconic heroes
of archie veronica and betty were all
told
no at first lily told kovetore that the
casting process was months long
and that they all worked incredibly hard
for the roles they finally secured
believe it or not
madeline pesch who plays evil cherry
blossom originally auditioned for betty
cooper we can't even imagine madeleine
being the nice girl
she plays the cold manipulative cheryl
so perfectly
cole sprouse auditioned for archie but
was always drawn to the role of jughead
cole liked that jughead was the show's
narrator meaning that his character
would have been around for a while
in the end after a four month casting
period and nationwide search they hired
their stars
changing the lives of those hired to say
the least the process seemed pretty
insane
we're just glad they found the perfect
actors to bring our comic book heroes to
life
lazy performers it's clear why the cw
network doesn't want this
nasty secret leaked no one wants to be
known as the show with unprepared actors
though we would never notice on screen
due to their incredible performances
however there are a couple of actors who
have admitted to memorizing their lines
the day of
lilly says in an interview on youtube
that the makeup chair is for memorizing
is it we understand there is a lot of
down time on set
but wouldn't you want to work on your
role or perhaps it is already in their
bones and they don't need to
either way cw obviously wants to keep
this under wraps the network is focused
on a younger audience and the last thing
they want to portray
is idols with lack of ambition they want
the riverdale cast to be people that
their fans can look up to
a cast that makes people never look away
from the small town
that being said prepared or not this
show has got us good
a scandal is a scandal and we'll tune in
to sip milkshakes and dig up secrets
with the cast of riverdale anytime
what do you think about the actors not
working on their scenes beforehand
let us know what you think below is
riverdale in montreal quebec
the show takes place in the moody
setting of a small fictional town called
riverdale where drama and secrets are
prevalent
however if you look closely there are
canadian hints planted everywhere
specifically from the french-speaking
city of montreal
so does riverdale actually take place in
montreal creator roberto aguiraza casa
was a student at mcgill university in
montreal and has for a long
time been obsessed with the archieverse
one montreal hint is the name of an
intimidating villain
paul belcher nicknamed papa poutine both
names
poutine and voucher are shout outs to
montreal
voucher led a gang in montreal during
the quebec biker war
and poutine well if you don't know what
poutine is you'll be happy to learn
it's a famous quebec junk food
consisting of a large heap of golden
fries
topped with squeaky cheese curds and
tasty gravy that's right a villain is
named for the late night snack
another easter egg the posters in
archie's room of his favorite band
heaven for real which is a band from
halifax the band themselves couldn't
believe it when their posters were
hanging in the famous character's room
guess having a creator who lived in
canada gave some nice shout outs to the
land he loved
have you noticed any more canadian hints
let us know in the comments below
copycats in 1990 pioneer david lynch
made waves with a dark
mystery series called twin peaks the
show became so popular that in 2017 a
follow-up series was remounted by the
same name
twin peaks obviously someone picked up
on the wide success and praise david
lynch received and took inspiration from
him however that isn't the only show
that has influenced riverdale yes the
crime-driven teenage soap has its
influences from many successful shows
gossip girl the oc and desperate
housewives all seem to have made their
mark in the series
most clearly though is twin peaks so do
you want to know where to spot these
copycat creators nods
in the pilot episode the opening
sequence is set in a forest with a
horrific crime scene playing over the
scene
is a whimsical pop song remind you of
any lynchian episodes
as the mystery unfolds with the popular
jason blossom's murder the backdrop for
the series is all
lust murder and dark secrets another
obvious hint of twin peaks influence is
casting
machine amick as alice cooper in
riverdale machine played the lead of
shelley in both the old and new version
of twin peaks do you think these hints
of inspiration from other shows were
meant to be kept secrets
or were they planted for avid fans did
you notice any more
hotter than the comics television is
condemned for mainly portraying for
lack of a better word hot casts cw takes
the cake on continuously hiring stunning
teenagers to rock the roles
so it isn't a surprise that when cw took
on creator roberto aguiras akasa's
steamy dark take on archie that they
wouldn't adjust the character's
appearances
shira archie and betty remained true to
the original comics however there
are roles that were drastically changed
miss gundy who in the source material
was a spindly grumpy teacher
is now a hotter than ever seductress
played by the talented
sarah hable jughead played by disney
star cole sprouse from the suite life of
zach and cody used to be the gluttonous
sidekick
is now turned into cute mystery digging
bud another less
obvious change is veronica played by
newcomer
camila mendes sure veronica fits the hot
profile of her original comic character
but where we meet her
she isn't the spoiled brat in fact she's
the trying to hard nice newbie
obviously attempting to make up for her
family's horrible past
cw still respects the original comics
they just like to spruce things up
anywhere they can
of course this is something the network
would prefer audiences not to know
deciding to only cast attractive people
is discrimination they bury the dark
secret in plain sight on screen but
let's face it the actors are insanely
talented and we wouldn't switch any of
them
kj appa pain endure our lovable football
dude and cute as always red hat teen
has been brilliantly brought to life by
new zealand actor kj appa however kj
hasn't necessarily gone scot-free from
the injury-prone character
he has racked up some of his own aches
and pains from filming the biggest of
them all was broken bones
while filming the epic action-packed
season 1 finale kj actually broke his
hand
in the finale cheryl blossom attempts to
end her life and if it weren't for
archie andrews she wouldn't have
survived archie repeatedly hits a slab
of ice
trying to save cheryl from her date with
death kj wore a cast
on screen ever since however the cast
was real show runner roberto aguirre
casa predicted this would happen he said
to comicbook.com that he warned those
on set that kj appa is such a committed
actor that they needed to watch he
wouldn't break his hand
so when roberto received a call later
confirming his prediction there was no
surprise
another minor incident that occurred
with kj was while bleaching his eyebrows
resulting in burned skin not as epic as
breaking
a hand but who knew turning a brunette
into a redhead could be dangerous
either way kj has sacrificed himself in
the name of art and in the name of
archie
lily reinhardt struggles with depression
betty cooper is a pivotal role in the cw
hit
her character is complex emotional and
of course
crushes hard on archie however that
takes a crazy turn when she falls for
jughead
hashtag what but that's not the dark
secret we're here to reveal lily
reinhardt the actor who brings the
blonde bombshell to life has some of her
own emotional turmoil
in 2017 lily admitted that she has
struggled with crippling anxiety
and depression the young star moved to
la to pursue her dreams but later moved
back home after one specifically severe
panic attack
lily is now an advocate for mental
health she posted many tweets during
mental health week in 2017 about the
importance of finding help adding that
everyone deserves to be happy lily
revealed that riverdale came into her
life during one of her darkest times and
she admitted it saved her her tweets
received a lot of support but almost
more backlash fans felt angry she was
just telling them to be happy when
depression is a struggle lily retorted
that she's dealt with it her whole life
and she was telling people to seek help
not simply to get over it the negative
comments to what she meant as positive
were taken wrong
cease and desist order we've all been
such devoted fans of a creator's work
that we just can't stop thinking about
it
roberto aguiras acasa took that to the
next level with his over-the-top
obsession with the archie comics
a lot has changed since 2003 when
roberto received a cease and desist
letter from archie comic publications
inc for writing a play where archie
comes out as gay however after
he wrote afterlife with archie which
placed the characters in a zombie
apocalypse roberto was hired as the
chief creative officer for the company
he continued to write adaptations of the
characters
reimagined such as chilling adventures
of sabrina which plays sabrina the
teenage witch in a vampire style
makeover
since roberto took over the revered
position at acp the last decade of
archie comics has
expanded greatly exploring gay
characters and alternate features
roberto's dedication and love for archie
have
expanded the brand itself and now even
created the crazy popular series
clearly his unwavering infatuation with
the comics and characters has led him to
great success roberto is now the
showrunner and creator of riverdale and
is praised for his genius in writing the
series
just goes to show that even if you
receive a cease and desist letter for
writing what some
call provocative behavior it doesn't
mean they're right
tragic car crash after a long 16 hour
shoot day
an accident occurred that could have
cost the production of the show when kj
appa drove himself home
after an arduous day on set he got in a
car accident the lead of the show was
exhausted and was not provided
transportation home
the hollywood reporter stated that kj
appa fell asleep at the wheel on his
45-minute drive home while filming in
vancouver the production has since been
on edge about the accident
kj was taken to the hospital after
striking a light pole he sustained
serious injuries and his car was totaled
from the amount of damage
cole sprouse who was terrifyingly going
to be in the car that night
requested from producer greg berlanti
that they have transport home the
production works the kids from morning
until night some were still afraid
things could take a turn for the worse
this secret sure doesn't look good for
the money-making folks who aren't taking
proper care of their overworked stars
we can't imagine the show without the
actors we love so dearly we're just
happy that kj is okay but let's face it
it could have been a tragedy
serious threats vanessa morgan is the
new kid on the block in riverdale
she's also the girl who's been receiving
some serious threatening letters for
what her role entails vanessa morgan
plays
tony topaz a bisexual who stirs the
drama pop between jughead and betty in
season
two the love triangle had some bugheads
aka
jughead fans seriously distraught
vanessa morgan is known for the
adventure science fiction series the
shannara chronicles
and the mtv drama finding carter now she
will be known for playing tony
in response to her numerous received
bullying and other serious threats
she has remained calm the letters were
received before the release of season
two and vanessa says she knows that fans
are just scared she will break apart a
favorite couple the pink haired gal is a
member of the south side serpents the
gang that jug had joined at the end of
season 1 which is where jughead meets
tony in an interview with glamour
vanessa revealed the serious threat she
received over her role
saying fans were jumping to conclusions
despite the fear this
must have caused vanessa was still
excited to play tony and contribute
positively to bisexual representation
you go fearless lady we couldn't agree
more what did you find was the most
shocking dark secret let us know in the
comments below
thanks for watching 10 dark secrets
riverdale try to hide see you next time